tony stark exists in the marvel
cinematic universe but so does robert
downey jr it may make your head hurt but
she-hulk proves it here's how the mcu is
very different from the real world but
over time through various references to
pop culture we're learning the common
threads between marvel's superheroes
lives and our own kendrick lamar beyonce
leonardo dicaprio keanu reeves patrick
swayze and kevin bacon all exist in the
mcu star wars is a real franchise within
the universe and dc comics apparently
exists too it's like alfred in batman
jack that's superman that that's humor
man jack it's really funny jack that is
definitely not superman some of the
actors who star in mcu movies are also
apparently real people within the
universe for instance tony stark calls
thor lebowski in avengers end game which
means the actor jeff bridges who played
obadiah stain and iron man exists in the
mcu or at least maybe he does more on
this in a bit episode 2 of she-hulk
attorney at law confirms that yet
another mcu actor also lives within its
fiction tony stark and robert downey jr
both apparently exist in the mcu thanks
to one of his projects playing on a tv
in the background the second episode of
she-hulk sees jennifer walters struggle
with getting a job after being let go
from her law firm because of her new
powers she's turned down at interview
after interview so before she's
approached by the ever so dry holden
holloway to join his firm jen sits
quietly at the bar and drinks her
sorrows away while ally mcbeal plays on
the tv just above her fans of the late
90s law comedy watched the titular
character played by kalista flockhart go
through several tumultuous relationships
one of those was with larry paul a
fellow lawyer portrayed by robert downey
jr in the fourth season larry was a
witty bostonian and the two seemed like
they were meant to be is this your
method no i have no method
only madness but larry had a child from
a former marriage who stayed in
massachusetts while he was in detroit
eventually larry went back to boston
though he and ally kept their
long-distance relationship going writers
were planning for the two characters to
wed but the washington post reported
downey was fired from the series over
drug-related charges while we don't see
downey on the screen in she-hulk it's
clearly ali mcbeal that's playing
she-hulk is strikingly similar to the
90's legal drama and its inclusion in
episode 2 was strategic writer jessica
gal revealed to variety we never really
talked about ally mcbeal or referenced
her because i would say most of our
writer's room was a little bit on the
young side to have really known that
show during its heyday but yes people
can't help but make the comparison to
ally mcbeal so ally mcbeal playing in
the bar was a choice made during
post-production if ally mcbeal and
robert downey jr exist in the mcu that
means every other member of the cast
does as well including bobby conovalli
who appeared in five episodes of ali
mcbeal and also plays the husband of
scott lang's ex in the ant-man films two
members of the x-men films cast also
appeared in the series famka janssen who
was jean grey in the x-men movies played
larry's ex-wife and james marsden who
was the x-men's cyclops played glenn foy
on the series there is of course a
logical explanation to how this all
could be accurate and not feature robert
downey jr and the rest of the marvel
actors in ally mcbeal in the mcu
different actors could play those roles
in the 1993 movie last action hero
arnold schwarzenegger plays a character
who is an actor and in his universe the
star of the terminator franchise was
sylvester stallone not himself so on
ally mcbeal instead of rdj it could be
amh playing the role you know anthony
michael hall can the mcu showrunners
really do that in their made up world
actually they can until we get an
official word or a later she-hulk
episode shows another ally mcbeal clip
in the background with robert downey jr
actually on screen we're not 100 what
the deal is we'll just hope that tony
stark enjoyed watching robert downey
jr's run on ally mcbeal back in the day